Brandon is in Memphis hey Brandon how
are you hey I'm doing great how are you
doing
better than I deserve what's up so I
have about a hundred left on my mortgage
and that's the only debt that I have and
[Music]
after I budget everything and pay all my
bills and everything and so I was
wondering would it be a good idea to
start investing $1,000 a month now or
just use that extra money to pay my
mortgage okay you ain't your debt free
except your mortgage you have your
emergency fund in place of three to six
months expenses I have about 10 grand
and savings all right then the next step
would be
baby steps 4 5 & 6 15 percent of your
income should be going into retirement
savings are you doing anything towards
retirement investing at this point nice
well not yet okay and what is your
household income about 50 grand okay
cool so 75 hundred a year would be 15%
of your household income and so you know
you just set that up do you have a 401 K
at work no okay you set that up as a
Roth IRA and you can do that I mean
basically knock it out with one Roth IRA
it's seven thousand dollars a year or
six thousand dollars or you can put in
it and so you can do a little bit in
your name are you married yeah okay a
little bit in your name a little bit in
your wife's name and put four thousand
and each if you want something like that
once you're doing that you set that up
as a monthly hit on your checking
account going straight into mutual funds
into a Roth IRA any money you have above
that baby step five and start to think
about kids college do you have kids
nothing okay then we skip that one and
baby step six is we pay everything else
to home the mortgage so what that does
is it gets you started with a real
serious investment now the how old are
you 22 okay if you invest fifteen
percent of your income for the rest of
your life you'll have ten million
dollars mm-hmm okay and and my wife my
wife isn't working
she's actually gonna start working
full-time when she gets out of school
yeah and say that asked for her school
up until now perfect and that will
increase then the 15% going into
retirement and on top of that then
you'll have more money to throw on at
that mortgage and knock that mortgage
out I suspect you're probably going to
be millionaires around 30 to 32 years
old that's pretty cool so let me ask you
this question real fast um if I could do
more than 15-percent should I know free
no everything else goes to the house one
tie off the house Oh once you do once
you pay off the house that's maybe step
seven then and there's nothing left to
do then but become very very wealthy and
be very very generous so yeah you max
out everything in your retirement and
you do more investing but you also do
some living there's only three things
you can do with money give it live it
and invest it right and you ought to be
doing some of all three all the time and
they're doing a really good job man I
mean you're you're a studly 22 year old
you got this going man I'm proud of you
very very well done